خلال الايام الماضيه اصبح حارس منتخب
العراقي السابق نور صبري حديث مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بسبب صوره نشرها
احتفالا بدخول ابنته كليه الطب الصوره
فتحت باب المتنمرين على مصراعيه لتطالب
كلماتهم المزعجه ابنه اللاعب دفعه لاخفاء
التعليقات على الصوره من حسابه على
انستجرام ورغم التنوع التنمر فان اصوات
كثيره دافعت عن صبري واكدتنا صبري مثال
للاب العظيم الذي يفتخر بابنته كذلك فقد
اكد المدافعون عن صبري ان التعليقات
منافيه للاخلاق بل دخيله على المجتمع
العراقي مشددين على ضروره التصدي لها لكي
لا تتكرر مثل هذه الافعال على كل حال
قضايا تنمر مشابهه شهدها المجتمع العراقي
مع مراسله صباح العربيه والتي ستكون معنا
لاول مره هنا في استوديو صباح العربيه وفي
اول اطلاله لها معنى زينب المشاط اليك
لم يكن نور صبري الوحيد من مشاهير العراق
الذي تعرض لحمله تنمر بسبب نشره صورته مع
ابنته الاعلامي العراقي عماد الخفاجي هو
الاخر تعرض قبل سنوات من الان الى حمله
مشابهه ولذلك اعلن الخفاجي تضامنه مع نور
صبري وابنته كذلك الشاعره العراقيه شهد
الشمري تعرضت لحمله مشابهه بعد نشر مجموعه
مقاطع فيديو مع عن ميلاد ابنتها نايل
وانتقدت كثيرا بسبب ذلك في موقف سابق تعرض
سفير العراق في الاردن الى هجمه غريبه بعد
نشر صوره هو وزوجته مع الفنان راغب علامه
وفي النهايه هذه الحالات مكرره لكنها لا
تعبر عن اغلب المجتمع انما هي لاشخاص
يتناسون ان الشخص المشهور هو انسان على كل
حال ويضعونه دائما تحت مجهرهم ليتجه الامر
من انتقاد لاعماله الى حملات تنمر حول
حياته الشخصيه على كل حال سال الناس في
العراق عن رايهم في التنمر الذي تعرض له
اللاعب السابق نور صبري وابنته
يمشي بالشارع ما هو الخلل المفروض
الاصوات هذه لا تمثل الذوق الشعب العراقي
ولا تمثل الواقع حضاري المفروض حريه الري
حريه الثقافه حريه الهويه من اجل بناء
مجتمع خالي من السلبيات مجتمع خالي من كل
شيء انسان حرب مطلق الحريه داخل صوره
بنتها مشكله مو مشكله بس احنا طول
العراقيين بنا ان نتنمر على شيء بسيط تنمر
يعني وين ما تروح موجود تنمر يعني احنا
نوصل فكره بين هي هاي حريه شخصيه
[موسيقى]
دول العالم تحتفي بنجومها وتكبرهم بل
تضعهم في المقدمه
وتعطيهم اهميتهم احنا البطلنا الدولي نور
صبري اللي هو حاصد الجوائز العلم العراقي
الكبير اللي رفع في كل المحافل كان بسبب
او ببطوله نور صبري كافي تنمر احنا مرات
نتنمر او نحكي على المحتويات الهابطه بس
يعني ما راح كل المحتويات احنا يعني
يعتبرها هابطه ومو زينه فالمفروض احنا
يعني قبل ما نحكي ونتنمر على الناس نعرف
حركاتنا وتصرفاتنا ونعرف على منو يحكي
بعدين نقوم نحكي
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من اربيل نور صبري الحارس
السابق للمنتخب العراقي يسعد صباحك يا نور
شكرا على تواجدك معانا تشرح لنا ما الذي
حصل ايش شو صار يعني ليش التنمر تحديدا يا
نور كيف شفت انت هذا التنمر
صباح الخير عليكم صباح الخير على كل
المشاهدين العربيه اكيد وصباح الخير على
الجميع
الحقيقه انا يعني من الشخصيات او من الناس
اللي
متفهم للوضع وين كنت حزين لطريقه التعامل
مع الصوره وهو ليس بالجديد بالنسبه لي انه
انا انزل صور مع اولادي بشكل مستمر احتفل
بهم واحتفي بهم في كل نجاح يقدموه لانفسهم
بالتالي يعني هذا انا اشعر بفخر كبير
واتعرض به الفتره والاخرى لامور تخص خاصه
لما تكون بناتي بالصوره يعني اولادي ماكو
عليها مشكله لكن لما يكون الموضوع يخص
البنت هنا المساله يعني مختلفه يمكن اكو
جزء انا فرحان بيه وسعيد هو طريقه تعامل
الناس او رده فعل الناس هذا يمكن يفتح باب
للتعامل اخر مع المراه ومع البنت يعني
بالتحديد لانه احنا بالفتره الماضيه ولا
لا يزال المراه والبنت يعني تتعرض دائما
لكثير من الاعتداءات والتحرشات اذا كانت
على المستوى الشارع على مستوى الاهل منع
ورفض دائما البنت هي دائما
اليوم تصف حاله يعاني منها الكثيرون اليوم
في المجتمعات خصوصا من جراء التعليقات
سوشيال ميديا بس كمان انا اسمح لي شخصيا
ارحب بوجودك معنا في برنامج صباح العربيه
على شاشه العربيه اولا وايضا نور كمان شو
تفسيرك لهذه الحاله على السوشيال ميديا عم
بنلاقي جيوش الكترونيه عم بلاقي اشخاص
يقومون ويتجراون بكل وقاحه على نشر
تعليقات موسيقى واعطاء رايهم وهم اصلا
مختبئين فوق الشاشه وفوق
نعاني يعني بصراحه بصريح العباره احنا
نعاني معاناه كبيره مع الناس يعني حتى
واحنا مثلا خلينا نقول نسوي عملنا الخاص
اعلاناتنا الخاصه شغل
اي شيء هناك معترضين لكل شيء وكانه
العمليه هي عباره عن لا يجب انه انتقد اي
قضيه مهما تكون بدون ما يعرف المحتوى
الحقيقي بدون ما يعرف في العبره من هذا
الفيديو او الصوره او الحكمه اللي تنزل عن
طريق السوشيال ميديا اعتقد المشكله
الحقيقيه هو عدم وجود الرقابه خاصه احنا
بالعراق عندنا مشكله بعدم وجود الرقابه
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لان الموضوع
بالحقيقه لما يتحول يعني يصير متطرف يعني
ويصير ديني وهذه الان تلعب بعقول الشباب
هذه مساله جدا خطيره يعني يعني احنا
كنعاني منها بشكل كبير لكن انا اعتقد ايضا
على عاتق المعنيين المسؤولين انه يكون
هناك رقابه مثل باقي دول الخليج هناك
رقابه على كل كلمه تكتب لانه احنا بصراحه
نتعرض الى تهديد ولا نتعرض حتى الى اسب
وشتم باللي عوائلنا بشتى الوسائل
اعتقد الشباب الرئيسي هو غياب الرقابه طيب
نور انت حجبت كل التعليقات على صورتك في
انستغرام ماذا تقول عبر شاشه العربيه
وصباح العربيه لكل المتنمرين
والله انا مسحتها على الفيسبوك ما كنت
اتخيل انه الموضوع اخذ اكثر من حجمه
الطبيعي بس مساحه الصوره على الفيسبوك
بالتالي ما قلت ندمت لكن تسرعت انهم
مساحتها لانه انا كنت خايف على بنتي فقط
لا اكثر انا ما اخاف من احد كل وقتي يعني
تعاملت مع نفسي ومع عائلتي انه دائما
متعودين على هذه الضغوطات التعليقات
هو الشخص الجمال والذي يبث سمومه وامراض
نفسيه الى العالم والى المستخدمين مع ذلك
انا اراعي المشارع المشاعر اولادي
والقريبين فحبيت انه اخفي لكن تبقى الصوره
مثل ما هي وانا ان شاء الله الله يخليلك
كل اولادك ويحفظ لك بناتك وشوفوا حالهم
فيك نور بس في كمان شغله هيك نقطه صغيره
انه احيانا بيقولوا انه المشهور او
المعروف خصوصا انت حارس سابها للمنتخب
العراقي ومشهور رياضيا ومعروف في العراق
بيقولوا لك انه لازم تكون اصلا متجاهل
ودائما في تصويب سهام على كثير من الناس
مثلا رؤساء دول يطالهم مسبات وتعليقات
موسيقى فبالتالي عليك ان تتحمل انت كيف
بترد على هاي النظريه
انا اقول انه اني بشر حالي حال الجميع
عندي مشاعر وعندي احاسيس واتاثر في بعض
الاوقات افرح واحزن بشر طبيعي لو كنت مو
طبيعي ممكن انا اكون مثل لو كنت حديد على
اللي اشوفه واللي يشوفوه اكيد اللي مثلي
يعني انا اشوفها صعبه جدا في بعض الاوقات
انا ما اتردد بالرد بقسوه على على البعض
لانه اكو كلمات بصراحه انت تعرفين واللي
يشوفني يعرف انه صعب يعني تجاوقات انه
يكون احنا يعني داخلي مقهور جدا يجب انه
اطلع يجب انه يعني اوضح لهذا الشخص انه
انت ما تقوله هذا هذا خطا كبير وتجاوز
علينا فلا انا ما اشوف انه يجب انه يتجاهل
ممكن في بعض الاوقات لكن مو كل وقت لانه
بصراحه صار تمادي بهذه نور
نعم انا فقط يعني ساختم معك واقول لك يبقى
الاب اوفى حبيب لابنته ولو احب هالعالم
شكرا جزيلا شكرا لك شكرا جزيلا من اربيلنا
نور صبري الحاره السابق للمنتخب العراقي